our Synergy and our chemistry and
everything is just so lovely today we're
manifesting some good behind the scenes
action of the final season of the nearly
dropped Netflix saved NBC show manifest
everybody there was so kind and great
scene partners and active collaborators
number one pulling teeth we can
understand ripping hair out would
definitely take this a step too far Luna
blace pulled some teeth on set Paisley
Herrera who plays Eden had her very
first wiggly tooth this season she lost
her first tooth they knew it had to come
out of course you know what I think
we're gonna have to just take it out
okay this turned out to be more Charming
than you were expecting we bet little
Paisley I totally tricked her number two
dancing was a good way to spend their
downtime besides they had plenty to
dance about after securing a fourth
season looks like Josh Dallas is all
tapped out now four seasons is all he
could take oh wait he's back number
three the best news is there's more to
come after season four wraps yes after
manifest ends the cast will be back with
a whole new show called Man vs banana
will you tune in do you think it will
make it to number one on Netflix too
sorry to troll you
number four how
how's things past security foam Blaster
fights in the hall we thought it was
called Show Business not show Friends oh
but there's kids involved that's fair
number five dinner is the show actually
when you're enjoying your food and
everybody's gotta criticize you let her
eat in peace
cereal was dropping out there now
number six there's too many little
things going on we can't list them all
so many quirky things on set pretending
to be witches on brooms that fantastic
70s disco look we love it something
tells us they were celebrating Halloween
number seven good first impressions are
everything the transition was was
seamless Luna Blaze helped make that
transition for Ty Doran so much easier
because she included him and taught him
and supported him and offered guidance
what a role model the first scene she
ever got to shoot with calstone will
always be Luna Blaze's most memorable
too bad that means no other moment will
ever live up to it because they had to
do an insane intense scene together but
it actually bonded us because now he is
like a real brother to me number eight
surprises wouldn't be surprises if you
weren't feeling absolutely terrible
before them right sort of trickled in
didn't it I feel like it wasn't like one
big moment do you remember a time when
manifest wasn't supposed to get a fourth
season yeah we've also blocked it from
our memory why NBC why when Luna Blaze
heard Netflix picked up the show she was
just chilling I was on the beach in
Malibu I actually found out found out at
a cast dinner on the hush hush anyway
most people did find it out that way yes
thank you Netflix you may be notorious
for canceling shows after a season or
two but you've also been known to save
them from time to time the show was
picked up for its fourth and final
season either coincidentally or
deviously smart on the 28th of August
828 that's also the number of the
airplane that crashed number nine six
Seasons or a movie well it ain't no
Community that's for sure this show was
actually supposed to get six seasons so
we didn't get everything we ever wanted
but at least we got some resolution so
writer Jeff rake was struggling to
figure out how to condense three seasons
into one into just 20 episodes we do not
envy you rake however he was willing to
condense those three seasons into a
two-hour movie if he had to so a season
is a pretty good deal he said when I've
talked to the past about having a road
map all the way to the end of series
that didn't mean that I had a road map
for literally every single episode I
have a road map with a series of twists
and turns and flags in the sand that we
would ultimately hit in order to tell
the core stories within our mythology
and within our relationship drama number
10. are you a lover of beards or a hater
there's no in between it was pretty easy
to slip back into their roles for season
four but Josh Dallas had at the top
toughest was it relatively easy to slip
back into these roles I grew a beard
yeah yep that's right he had to grow a
beard ugh imagine growing a beard we
wonder how Jennifer Goodwin felt about
it number 11. we'd sing but um we're
just getting over a thing enjoy some
cake cough cough J.R Ramirez celebrated
his birthday on set with a beautiful
cake by the looks of those pumpkins he's
a fall baby yep October 8th you gotta
love having an in-person job where they
buy you real cake on your birthday oh
the dream number 12 the directors are
the noobs not the actors let's just make
that 100 clear Melissa roxberg and Josh
Dallas directed for season four so our
boss here who who trusted us and gave us
a chance and it sure worked out for
Melissa she had a blast and was glad
everyone just listened to her she found
it really fun being on the other side of
the camera and is hoping to do that more
there's a ton of support from everyone
and she's played Michaela Stone so long
it wasn't too tough the cast liked
working with both Melissa and Josh as
directors because they explained things
like actors not like directors and it
just made more sense to them that feel
when you're gifted a director jacket
number 13 we always love a good laugher
onset what is supposed to bring so much
energy and charm to the room just ticks
off the guy getting muscle cramps from
holding the boom mic so long working
with Melissa is challenging because when
she corpses on set she just can't stop
she's the one that had the hardest time
um keeping it together I guess so to
speak number 14 no they aren't giving us
a body swap episode You Wish J.R Ramirez
if he could play any other characters on
the show it would be Matt Long's
character Zeke Landon because he's one
of the most complex characters on the
show he's got so much to sink his teeth
into number 15 do not share nudes hoard
them hoard them all for yourself if
somebody's eating nudes in the
background and nobody's there to witness
it did it even happen the internet says
yes number 16 every day is one more day
on the set of manifest the cast didn't
think they'd get quite naturally they'd
party however drinking on set struggling
with the wine opener look at that face
You Can Tell She's an actor number 17.
we love a good church fight whatever
that entails the mid-season finale
Church scene is set in Saint Paul's
Episcopal Church in Glen Cove on New
York's Long Island Jeff rake said we
have a very tenacious location manager
the set had very subtle special effects
because the beautiful location did most
of the work for them number 18.
congratulations to the graduating cast
of 2022. you almost didn't get there
ending this show felt like graduating
while it was hard for the cast to say
goodbye to each other because they had
such a beautiful Synergy they're also
incredibly proud of what they were able
to create best people in the world to
work with you know so it was very
emotional very very emotional number 19.
wakey wakey nightmares and shaky this
wasn't season four but we've got a
theory perhaps Jake Messina was waking
up to to the reality that the show was
canceled well he didn't come back even
though it was picked back up so season
three really was the end for the poor
guy what's weird about film is when you
don't speak you can receive directions
from the director because audio doesn't
matter number 20. are you prepared for a
game of eye spy that takes more than
your eyes the number 828 can be found in
every episode in some way or hinted
towards like Michaela's apartment number
is half that at 4 14 very intentional
are you going to have to go back and
re-watch to find them all now and did
you know that all the episode titles are
based on airplanes or air travel
well it looks like it was a ton of fun
on set for the Manifest fam do you think
they were manifesting season four every
manifest Monday what was your reaction
when you found out it was coming back
let us know in the comments and thanks
for hanging out with us here at the
things